you know in your pantry you have all
these spices and herbs you want to make
sure that they last as long as possible
so in this video i'm going to talk about
the expiration date on spices and herbs
so with spices you usually have
different blends of dried roots
bark
or the stem and usually spices last
anywhere between two and three years
then you have herbs which are the dried
leaves like basil oregano thyme rosemary
mint bay leaves dill parsley cilantro
sage and typically they will last
anywhere between one and three years but
then we have the whole spices as in
whole peppercorn coriander mustard seeds
fennel seeds caraway seeds cumin seeds
clove
and cinnamon sticks which lasts
four years or even longer so you might
want to consider getting most of your
herbs in a whole form and then just get
a grinder now what happens when these
herbs have an expired expiration date
well they're still okay to take they
just might lose flavor potency and color
but they're not going to make you sick
unless they have gotten some moisture
and there's some mold growing in that
product now i know in my pantry i
probably have
herbs still in there from maybe seven
even 10 years ago we still use them on
occasion but they're just not as strong
now when you're storing herbs make sure
they're in glass
sealed bottles with the top really tight
because air moisture and light can
degrade these herbs a lot faster make
sure they're in a dark place and make
sure they're not exposed to heat so you
wouldn't want to store them right by the
oven now if you have oil seeds like in
sesame seeds poppy seeds
i would recommend refrigerating those
because the oils do turn rancid a little
bit faster so anyway i just wanted to do
this video to answer someone's question
on the expiration date on spices and
herbs
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i would really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others